in the town of Phil Borden north of
Brussels these young men are buddies
they're mostly for Muslim families
they're almost like a gang the soccer
field is their kingdom and they're the
ones in charge here hey don't talk with
the reporters all they're going to do is
make us look bad stop filming stop but
then if you do speak with us they say
they feel ambivalent and stigmatized
ever since almost 30 youths from the
Vorta went to Syria recently recruited
by extremists to fight for is I don't
like thinking about it sometimes it's
people you know and who come back dead
I'm against these guys going to Syria
that's my opinion
Mourad elbow dotty knows almost all of
the young men who went to Syria he
himself was able to resist the false
prophets his parents are devout Muslims
who taught him that war is not holy
these guys really believed they have to
take part in the fighting for them jihad
is an ideal and they want to follow this
ideal the Imams and Belgium's mosques
have lost their influence over many
young people in the suburbs now they
want to offer orientation on the
internet to stop hate propaganda from
luring young people the prophets of the
Lord was in the siq Winnick there were
active on Facebook our Quran teachers
call on their students to engage with
radicalize young people on Facebook and
use arguments to show them Islam is a
religion of peace and love the other
side the fanatics don't use arguments
they snare the gullible with dubious
prophecies the website sharia4belgium
tells young Muslim
they will one day rule the theocracy in
Belgium the website is now banned its
leaders have been convicted of terrorist
activities dimitri bond tank was one of
those who took part in the litigation
his son ian had fallen into the clutches
of the extremists and gone to Syria
Dmitri risked his own life to bring him
back he's bitter about how the belgian
state left him in the lurch
of course we asked help by the
authorities by the police by youth
organizations and the answer was they
couldn't do something because there was
a freedom of organization there was
freedom of speech there was freedom of
religion you know they were laughing
with me that took me as a clown you know
what they said to me that is not even my
business to know where is my son
that's excuse me I'm a father the
Belgian state has come in for much
criticism for years the country has been
strongly divided so Belgium is finding
it harder than most other European
countries to integrate foreigners that's
what Islam expert uncle MOT Luwak says
in the last 20 years Belgium has not
forcefully fought against radical Islam
and now it's become a huge problem also
due to Belgium's lack of unity must have
taken advantage of the lack of
coordination between the Flemish and
well own communities the country's
security forces are alarmed and the
police are out in force but for the
mayor of vigau de that's only the first
step before this possible - we need more
facilities for young people and new
schools we also need more sports
facilities because I think sports
promotes integration watch aqualantic
ratio of aussi Palace poor
we'll see you need to look at the
problems here in Belgium what pushed
young people to go to Syria
they didn't just wake up one day and say
I want to go to Syria because it seems
to be great there it's part of a process
these youths no longer feel accepted by
Belgian society but even the young
people in vivo de know there are ways to
avoid becoming the target of hate
mongers most of them just want to be
accepted and become a part of Belgian
society